innov sinon tu meurs ça c'est mon ami à
moi
alors attention c'est pas d'intérêt
celle c'est pas d'intelligence
automatique avec laquelle nous les
humains on a trop tendance à la
confondre non c'est ce que j'appelle
l'innovation hal gill la capacité à
transformer son environnement à
l'améliorer al transmuté en quelque
sorte alors en préambule
quand on parle d'innovation souvent
l'appliquent à des génies scientifiques
mathématiques l'innovation ayant une
furieuse teinture textes de nos jours
pour moi l'innovation elle est partout
en gastronomie en architecture en
littérature en poésie en psychologie en
management partout l'innovation et ce
n'est pas qu'une question d'algorithmes
et pourtant derrière cette pluralité
d'innovation il ya un profil commun
c'est celui d'innovateur et là encore
contrairement à la pensée commune on
n'est pas face à un spécialiste de la
discipline qui confortablement installé
dans son statut ce dur est pas mal ce
monde il serait mieux si j'ajoute est
ceci ou cela non très souvent on est
confronté à un abîme de détresse une
grande solitude un sentiment de
déréliction
en clair pour beaucoup d'innovateur
s'agit pas seulement d'améliorer le
monde mais plutôt de trouver les moyens
d'y rester dit survivre en quelque sorte
c'est pour ça pour moi l'innovation
c'est avant tout une pulsion et on n'est
pas dans le cerveau néo corticale de la
recherche du beau du bien de la
créativité d'imagination
non on est dans une pulsion qui
s'articule dans le cerveau reptilien
savent où la survie très souvent pour
les innovateurs il s'agit de se créer un
espace espèce de niche un écosystème
dans lequel ils vont pouvoir continuer à
vivre et ainsi de créer et aussi
peut-être par ce cadeau offert au monde
qu'est l'innovation de se donner le
droit de vivre une forme de rédemption
c'est pour ça que cette pulsion pour moi
elle est très personnel
la sueur elle s'habille ensuite de
considérations vertueuse altruiste on
innove pour améliorer le monde
pour faire progresser l'humanité oui à
partir d'une dynamique foncièrement
individuel de salut individuel alors qui
suis-je pour énoncer ce point de vue
parce que quelqu'un à qui l'innovation a
beaucoup apporté parce qu'elle ne
s'adresse pas simplement ou génie vos
people de ce monde
à titre personnel elle m'a fait elle m'a
offert parcours non rectiligne déjà sur
le plan professionnel m'a fait écumé
beaucoup des statuts professionnels
existants j'étais fonctionnaire
française fonctionnaire européen
j'ai été salarié d'une société française
salariés coach et l'oeil d'une société
de conseil anglo saxon auteurs
professions libérales gérante de société
tous avatar d'une capacité d'innovation
non mais je dois le dire par la noble
ambition d'innover pour le monde mais
plus prosaïquement par la nécessité de
sauver ma peau alors en préambule je
dirais que je suis un rescapé d'une
enfance de d'indifférence et de
violences je ne m'appesantirai pas et je
peux créer juste une scène j'ai 15 ans
c'est un dimanche matin
je suis dans ma chambre la fenêtre est
ouverte et je contemple mon suicide
sauter ou pas en alternative à cette vie
misérable sans amour non je fais le tour
de mon bureau j'attrape une copie double
je me plonge dans un devoir de maths
deux heures d'évasion jeu rend une copie
impeccable je cesse aussi de manger ça
c'est ce que j'ai appelé après le
premier éclair d'innovation agile
l'anorexie active douloureusement menée
pendant deux ans elle m'a permis
premièrement d'honorer mon désespoir à
quoi bon nourrir cette villa
et ensuite de transmuter l'effervescence
hormonal de l'adolescence dont j'avais
déjà perçu des prémices dérangeante ont
fait remonter l'énergie du bas ventre
jusqu'à la tête ça donne un cerveau
d'adultes dans un corps d'enfant ce que
j'avais vu des grandes personnes venant
mais pas du tout du tout du tout envie
de les rejoindre
boost phénoménal me voici des cochons la
première mention très bien de mon lycée
de province
ralliant une excellente pré pas
parisiennes intégrant normale sup dans
la foulée et réussissant très tôt la
greg ne plus avoir de corps ça fait mal
mais ça aide
deuxième est clair d'innovation agile
l'agrégation c'est bien beau mais elle
entraîne des affectations un peu rude
pour les jeunes diplômés sans point
d'ancienneté territoires désertés
province lointaine 100 ter à l'époque ni
tgv
le spectre de la maltraitance repointe
son nez
tout ça pour ça basta souffrir non je
refuse la mutation et je me retrouve
sans ressources seul à 20 ans dans paris
et l' urgence et à la fin des années 80
j'ai observé qu'il y avait un phénomène
qui émergeait qui était celui de
l'entreprise il y avait des émissions de
télé des magazines a un point commun
avec moi une forme de littérature
je dois dire parce que j'ai découvert
les magazines économiques avec un
certain effarement et comme un mouflon
un soir j'appelle le rédacteur en chef
de l'expansion qui me paraissent être le
plus beau donc le plus susceptible de me
proposer des piges et je reçoit un
excellent accueil du rédacteur en chef
heureux de recevoir une normalienne car
me dit-il en m'accueillant à l'expansion
grand amateur de littérature classique
ah bon il est où votre gaffiot je lui
réponds en entrant dans son bureau alors
préambule pour les non littéraires le
gaffiot désigne un
un dictionnaire franco latin une sorte
de briques de papier près internet
propre au cursus de tous les terreurs et
qui perçoit me suivait partout au point
qu'il me semblait normal pour qu'ils se
disaient amateurs de littérature
classique de l'avoir dans son bureau à
l'expansion non cette réplique mme à
distinguer aux yeux du rédacteur en chef
qui m'a confié quelques articles des
reportages de quoi observer qu'il y
avait un tropisme vers l'europe de l'est
et la russie
et ça ça tombait bien parce que
troisième est clair d'innovation agile
c'est ce que j'ai appelé le stretch
identitaire comme mon contexte familial
ne me rendais pas heureuse
je m'étais recréer une nouvelle identité
j'étais passionné de littérature
toujours mais moins intensément
littérature russe notamment et de
tolstoï qui pour moi était une belle âme
torturée en quête constante de
contributions monde
il avait fait construire des écoles pour
les enfants de ses moujiks sur ses
terres pour inciter protecteur idéal
généreux et j'avais décidé de me
rapprocher de lui comment ben en
apprenant sa langue toute seule ma psy
du mans et à raison de plusieurs heures
par jour au bout de trois ans je parlais
suffisamment bien le russe pour pouvoir
interviewer les artistes des peintres
des sculpteurs qui déferlaient en europe
et particulièrement en france avec la
pérestroïka la chute du mur de berlin
et c'est cette même compétence qui m'a
permis par la suite d'être recruté par
la commission européenne détaché par mon
gouvernement à la commission européenne
pendant cinq ans sur la c8 et ensuite
d'intéresser un cabinet de conseil ou
anglo saxons pour cette même compétence
le tout je tiens à le préciser sans
avoir le moindre diplôme universitaire
sur cette langue sur cette zone
géographique
voilà alors c'est quelques éclairs
d'innovation agile bien sûr ils m'ont
permis de me faire confiance
sans toutefois calme et totalement ou en
tout cas qu'elle ment partiellement
cette fêlure voilà c'est une fêlure
partiellement maîtrisé avec laquelle je
vis mais c'est aussi ça l'innovation
agile la nécessité de capter son
environnement dont il est jamais sûr
et puis la capacité à transmuter
l'angoissent en impulsions
et comme la raison suffisait pas à me
rassurer j'ai aussi ouvert d'autres
capteurs j'ai compris que l'intuition
cette capacité à appréhender les signaux
faibles les signes les synchronicité
pouvait être mon allié pour surfer sur
les sur les vagues de mon destin
parce que l'intuition c'est le code
source de l'innovation agile personnel
elle m'a permis déjà de transformer ma
ma thèse de doctorat en romans et
détruire ensuite neuf autres livres elle
m'a offert une famille de sang de coeur
et d'amis elle m'a fait voyager
déménager énormément de fois et aussi
elle m'a mise sur la voie du métier de
psychanalyste et de coach que j'exerce
depuis maintenant 15 ans à ma place
alors fin d'exemple personnel et puis je
vais maintenant illustrer ce point de
vue par d'autres figures plus
fondamental plus universel qui pour moi
incarne cette ce point de vue de
l'énergie enfin de la pulsion derrière
l'innovation pulsions très individuel
j'ai pris 4 personnes 4 personnages
illustres volontairement éclaté dans le
temps et dans l'espace
j'ai commencé avec coco chanel alias
gabrielle chanel elle est née dans une
famille de forains provinciaux elle perd
sa maman à 12 ans son père la place
comme bonne enfant dans une maisonnée où
elle coud à 24 ans c'est assez tard pour
l'époque elle est prise d'une pulsion
d'innovation agit d elles sautent sur le
l'estrade d'un café théâtre de moulins
où elle pousse la chansonnette
bingo elle tape dans l'oeil d'un
aristocrate de province qui l'initié aux
rudiments d'avis la haute société et
qu'elle sèmera assez vite poussé par les
innovations qu'on connaît la petite robe
noire la ligne garçonne le bandeau dans
les cheveux le joker le parfum éponyme
je n'aimais pas ma vie alors j'ai créé
ma vie a dit un jour coco chanel
exit gabrielle chanel
deuxième exemple steve jobs que je ne
vais pas aborder ici sous l'angle tech
steve jobs un jour confié dans une
conférence fameuse qu'il était enfin
adopté et qu'il considérait je cite ses
parents biologiques comme simplement une
banque de sperme et de gamètes
waouh et pour autant steve jobs a passé
l'essentiel de sa vie à travailler sur
la communication via l'informatique et
plus spécifiquement va cette innovation
génial qu'est l'iphone aux liens entre
deux personnes pour moi il ya une vraie
puce ion de connexion ici puissamment
transmuter troisième exemple grâce à qui
on est là aujourd'hui
thomas edison inventeurs du cinéma de
l'électricité de la prise de son tomasz
edison grosse pulsions d'innovation
agile il commence à créer ces
expériences très tôt à 10 ans il sert le
café dans un petit train qui emmène des
hommes d'affaires d'une ville à l'autre
parce qu'à l'époque les enfants
travaillent et où ont ils fait son café
sur le réchaud puis en même temps une
petite expérience de chimie comme ça et
l'expérience de trop bas il fait sauter
son wagon dix ans ses parents lui un
sale compréhensif l'install fils à un
laboratoire sous la maison et ils
continuent à présent ils attrapent la
scarlatine qui le laisse sourds maladie
qu'il qualifiera de voix la maladie mais
ont permis d'échapper aux conversations
et aux bavardages sans intérêt de ce
monde
on a une belle pulsions ici pas très
limbique pas très dans la connexion aux
autres très anti sociale
la question est temps pour thomas edison
comment survivre à mon époque la réponse
derrière la paillasse il a passé
soixante quatorze années de sa vie
il est d'ailleurs mort en situation à
west orange sur son site de production
industrielle nous laissant
près de 1000 brevets dernier exemple
arthur rimbaud né à charleville sharon
stone disent-ils pour sublimer enfant
d'une famille de cinq enfants son père
capitaine abandonne sa mère déshonoré
déclassé midi elle se réfugie dans un
quartier ouvrier ou évidemment son fils
se fait copieusement humilié arthur
rimbaud sans d'obéissance collectionner
prix d'excellence
jusqu'à ce que cros pulsions
d'innovation très agile il fugue il part
pour paris
évidemment ils sèment des treize
tournois son passage gros stress de sa
maman fiasco conjugales de son amant
verlaine emporté par la tornade rimbaud
et c'est pas fini
il crée il crée et vert sublime de la
littérature française le vers libre le
symbolisme laisse toujours pas fini à
presque 20 ans changement de programme
il apprend l'anglais l'allemand
l'italien il s'enrôle dans la marine
néerlandaise et devient bourlingueur
interlope entre eux l'europe l'abyssinie
on a un révolutionnaire de la
littérature française qui par dix les
des épices pour des roitelets exotique
au fin fond du désert en afrique
grosse grosse grosse pulsions
d'innovation radicalement personnel
totalement incompréhensible qui par
défaut servira à construire le mythe
alors évidemment à travers ses 4 exemple
je ne cherche pas à promouvoir une
vision de l'innovation comme
radicalement pulsionnel antisocial
rebelles dangereuse voire simplement je
tiens à mettre en évidence le caractère
hors cadre de l'innovation ses ressorts
pulsionnel sa nature viscérale on innove
pour raisons de vie ou de mort
sinon ça reste au niveau de
l'aménagement et gothique de la
cosmétique
ça va pas très loin alors ce point de
vue le mien bien sûr fondée sur mon
expérience mes observations et l'exemple
que j'ai cités mais il y en a d'autres
ils m'inspirent quelques idées que je
voudrais faire passer aux instances qui
promeuvent l'innovation génome et bien
évidemment les établissements éducatifs
les associations et surtout les
entreprises qui les encourage et les
finances et les provinces puissamment le
premier c sortons de l'angélisme de la
vision sainte de l'innovateur qui aurait
pour le bien du monde
parfois il est novateur il est pas
sympathique il est pas sociable il est
fermé et c'est pas son sujet on innove
pour soi parce qu'on n'a pas le choix
deuxièmement ouvrons-nous à la
différence il y a beaucoup dans les
entreprises de lieux où se développe la
créativité comme par exemple les cercles
de co développement
les séances d'intelligence collective
les programmes de méditation de pleine
conscience tout avatar de la pensée
positive qui nous vient en droite ligne
des états unis
c'est remarquable ça fait monter le
niveau de conscience dans les
entreprises encouragent la créativité
l'innovation il m'arrive parfois d'un
animé tout ça est très bien et pour
autant ce n'est pas valable pour tout le
monde
peut-être que l'innovateur il a pas
envie d'y aller il faut le laisser seul
écorché malheureux y livre une oeuvre à
peut-être plus que écartelé dans une
normalisation forcé et enfin mon dernier
message mais je le dédie aux innovateurs
en germe en chemin en devenir ou déjà
confirmés
accueillez ce sentiment de ne pas
convenir
cette inadéquation 7,7 tristesse cette
détresse cette déréliction parfois
accueilli cela parce que c'est votre
faye et cie voulu honorer
elle vous conduira un espace un espace
personnel qui n'a rien à voir avec les
programmes d'orientation les codes
sociaux
mais cet espace il sera d'autant plus
vaste que le manque à vivre était
puissant
et accueillez le honorer le cet espace
rempli c'est lui avec votre tête votre
coeur vos tripes vos idées vos émotions
vos sentiments vos impulsions
parce que là vous inaugurez et là vous
vous donnerez le droit de vivre mieux
vous vous donnerez du plus à vivre parce
que ça se sera hors cadre et quand c'est
hors cadre vous le savez c'est forcément
meilleur
[Applaudissements]